no
no no no
i'm gonna drew's real quick this is kurt
chambers on guitar over here
and this is miss taylor lynn hi y'all
everybody
hello now uh
taylor uh
she came to me about writing a song
together and do you want to tell her
tell everybody why yeah i do you were
the perfect person to come to my
grandmother is loretta lynn and she
writes
[Applause]
she writes her truth and it's my 10-year
anniversary with my husband this year
and we've really been going through
yeah some new stuff we're at a new
period in our marriage and so i came to
josh we could write a song together she
wanted to write a song about something
that her and her husband had been
talking about and i just think it's
probably pretty universal for a lot of
couples
and so uh but i thought i would we would
put it to a song that um that beth liked
also
uh so we could ruin that one as well
yeah
um but uh
whenever you're ready i am yeah
yeah oh wait a second oh oh whoa oh
tiger shoe i didn't put my shoes on
that's all right because i felt like i
should come out in my uniform feeling
just as sexy as i could i like your
sparkling paint yeah well this is conway
twitty's wife's shirt
well
yeah his widow what's that nothing
[Applause]
all right here we go
[Music]
tell me something girl
are you ready to give it
[Music]
whatever makes you the most comfortable
and you
told me
[Music]
we could try it on our 10th anniversary
well my
dear
decades up
the time is here
[Music]
tell me something boy
it you could go first it just seems fair
you
tell me
[Music]
for better words from here to eternity
what's the big deal we do lots of crazy
stuff
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah i was trying to hold it into oh my
god
[Music]
now
hey
[Music]
i'll try a finger
don't let it linger we're talking about
ain't no now
if i'm being honest i'm scared that i
like it we're talking
[Music]
[Applause]
no
[Music]
now
[Applause]
thank y'all so much thank you
[Music]
my
and foreign you aside
[Music]